[Musique]
depuis des siècles
mystérieux phénomène transforme les
côtes de la guyane
littoral se déplacent des forêts de
mangroves apparaissent
[Musique]
perdu au milieu d'une nature sauvage et
hostile
une équipe de scientifiques un trépied
décide de percer ce mystère
sur mer
sur terre et dans les airs ces
aventuriers d'un nouveau genre ont tenté
de cartographier le littoral le plus
dynamique du monde
[Applaudissements]
une quête de réponses pour comprendre
les transformations d'un territoire où
l'homme est à la merci de la nature
[Musique]
cet été en voulez vous pour une aventure
hors du commun à la découverte de
phénomènes qui n'ont pas fini d'étonner
la science